and he comes the most unusual part and
not everyone does it this way if you
have another way that you like which
works for you that's fine with me but
this is what I found is very useful and
it's very helpful for us extension to
students the R stands for regions let me
explain this for you it's time to
actually draw something with a lots of
like pre-work now it's time to put pen
to paper on a graph how I look at the
features that you're gonna need to put
on here and let's choose an appropriate
sort of space to do this in okay I'm
gonna put in all of the features I'm
already aware of so x equals 2x is 3x
equals 2x equals 3 what else make it
funny
in this episode I got 0 didn't use that
time okay I've also got the horrors last
time so I'll check that
you should label all of these things
okay have I accounted for everything so
far are you happy with it yeah good okay
now for this bit that's next we're gonna
struggle
yeah we'll do this one okay what I'm
gonna do now is remember that we
factorize earlier okay ah here we go
one two three four factors that have
been multiplied and divided together in
some water okay I want you to imagine
these now notice it functions but it's
just numbers okay now if I gave you four
positive numbers and I didn't tell you
what their sizes were their magnitudes I
just told you they were positive and you
multiply them together you wouldn't know
very much about the size of the answer
but you should know a lot about the
direction the sign of the answer what is
the scientific clearly a C+ there's
nowhere for a negative to a crept in
right so if you have four positive
multi-meter you get a positive what
about if I divided one of they said it
was a plan what do you think still be
the same right again there's no way for
a negative to creep in okay now I can do
this with different combinations so for
positive I could go like one positive
one negative not just do three negatives
how about that okay if you've got plus
an even three negatives and we'll sign
baby yeah like these guys are gonna
cancel and then these guys just give you
a negative
now therefore I'm now gonna stop here
numbers and think about these factors I
know what these factors look like before
exempting why cuz X I can plot y equals
excellent if you've got like a white
pencil that we perform at the planet
pathos so I'm just kind of Judy's
daughter
that's a wife with X looks like
sometimes it's then you get sometimes
suppose what about X minus 2 there's
another one my factors and X minus 3 X
minus 1 I draw all of them this is
Google luckiest X - there's X minus 2
you come okay alright so now I want to
think about how these factors contribute
to each other as I multiply and divide
them at different combinations
let's go from left to right okay well
the left-hand side over here if you look
to the left of x equals 0 I know I
haven't drawn them all the way but look
at all four are the factors do you see
they're all going to be negative over
here right were you going to make even
think of a negative a negative when you
multiply divide there is some
combination what sign we get for
negatives cancel cancel positive okay so
therefore when I put them all together
which is what this is
throw them all together right there is
always positive okay so I'm going to 0
magnetic positive okay I'm going to
shade in this over here so to the left
of this point four factors come together
they're all negative so the result has
to be positive
the regions I'm shading are going to
tell me where the function has to go
okay let's have a look at here in
between x equals 0 and x equals 2 look
at what happens look at your 4 factors
this one has transition from negative to
positive so I've got one positive factor
and how many negative factor 2 1 2 I
always have 4 in total in fact that's
this situation here isn't it right
positive negative negative negative
yes so when I combine them all together
their sign is going to be needed you see
that so that goes all the way up to
there do you see that and in fact you
start getting a bit higher so this was
not by just it just swaps every time you
know
have a look in this little region right
I've got two positive and I've got two
negatives multiplying or dividing some
combination two pluses to negative gives
you a because you're multiplying these
black dog lands together or dividing it
doesn't matter I've got two more inches
to go right so you between here and key
are positive positive positive negative
it just swaps back and forth every
single time and then the last one the
last one is positive positive positive
positive of course you're gonna end they
go so that was the art I shaded the
regions okay we did a lot of pre-work
that took some time cuz you're not
familiar with this process but now I'm
done now I just have to make everything
fit again that's different that too
right I've got a horizontal asymptote
that I need to approach right and then
I've got to come down to this intercept
yeah this would be X mins and then
whatever is down here what's what's
going on I'm negative and I've got to
get towards this asymptote do you see
that just not a crazy shape it's gonna
look like this right that's all that has
to do you see how it stays in my regions
and it goes through my intercepts and it
approaches both the asymptotes I know
it's supposed to you with me so far okay
all right now it's a little bit busy but
you can see I've got this area shaded
what's gonna happen up here have a look
notice I've got two vertical asymptotes
and I can't cross and I've gotta stay
positive
yeah
looks to me like it's gonna be something
like this
I can parabola East sort of shape now
will point out I don't know whether my
cost a lot but I don't really care that
much because this horizontal asymptote
does he do I care about you in the
movement rebirth it's all no relevance
to me I can go away from it I can go
through it no big deal okay it only
tells me at the edges there's a look
good so far have I have I stayed in the
right regions over here once bit do you
see I've got to go to negative here I'm
gonna pass through the axis and then I'm
gonna positive up here but I've got an
asymptote to go to so do you see yeah so
I'm gonna go like that that's it